[Music]
animals are really difficult here you're
doing a big big movie what's it like
working with a kitten time is money
you know the kittens got to do what you
want it to do and you can't waste time
how'd it work out yeah and we remained a
mistake of writing an entire cat movie
before we realized that I that I'm
definitely allergic to cats
oh you're allergic can't be around it
can't be within within 500 feet of a cat
right so we were like okay well that's a
dilemma and they were already on set
doing production how are we gonna solve
our cat issue we got this idea up right
and what we decided to do is through the
magic of motion caption mocap mocap we
we hired another actor to play Keanu
yes what do mean you hired an actor to
play I think kind of like a CGI thing
yeah yeah the actors here right yeah we
back stage right now I don't know if you
want to bring you wanted to bring them
out see you meet him yeah
[Applause]
okay okay this is the so this this this
is this is this is sandy Perkis sandy
purchase dog played the cat right and
I'm not allergic to dogs at all so this
this solves all of our problems are you
okay holding I think you should take
pretty cute yeah sandy I sandy it did
such good work so that's good work so
the sandy sandy is the premier mocap its
dog in in Great Britain and he is this
the first this is the first role playing
Keanu as a cat the CGI this is the first
african-american cat that he's played
but this is probably his first
african-american casting yeah sandy come
on this is this is a bit come on we need
that we need you to cooperate here sandy
okay okay here we go alright he feels he
feels very cute in his mocap suit and
he's done other roles but he's played
he's mocap for other people what do you
mean well what other stuff has he done
oh he well I believe in a Magic Mike
metal by cell he played Channing he was
Boardwalk Empire fans here yes but I
mean Santa semi hasn't he played
solution for the last 10 years for the
last ten years last 10 years on hiatus
for a decade alright fans here that was
sandy burkas who did all that work what
incredible it did create some problems
when we had the the mailman scene and of
course you know it doesn't make sense to
have a kitten jump and chases you don't
typically see who's chasing squirrels
yeah Tim it's and we have that issue
don't feel like you have to laugh yeah
I don't wanna I don't want to we don't
want any burqa sure is it Fergus is
unsettling called oh that's really I've
never seen a dog look like oh this
[Applause]
you